The universe looks like a vast empty ocean
sprinkled with the rare islands of galaxies..
But this is an illusion. Just a small
fraction of all atoms are found in galaxies,
while the rest is thought to be drifting
in between, in the intergalactic medium.
Like the roots of some massive tree,
gas spreads out from each galaxy,
gravity funneling fresh mass
into this dense, cosmic forest.
Here in the intergalactic medium, are the raw
materials of creation: hydrogen and helium,
woven into sheets and filaments that flow into
galaxies where they eventually create stars.
But if we look closely, we see who is actually in
charge: Quasars, the single most powerful objects
in existence. As small as a grain of sand compared
to the amazon river, they reside in the centers
of some galaxies, shining with the power of a
trillion stars, blasting out huge jets of matter,
completely reshaping the cosmos around them.
They are so powerful that they can kill a galaxy.
What are they, and how do they mold the
structure of the universe at their whim?
Everywhere You Look, Weird Things in the Sky
In the 1950s astronomers noticed mysterious
loud radio-waves coming from spots all over
the sky. They were named “quasi-stellar
radio sources”, or “quasars” because they
were dots like stars, but were seen in
radio waves rather than visible light.
Everything about them was strange. Some flickered,
others emitted high energy X-rays in addition to
radio waves, but all seemed to be tiny. They
also moved extremely fast, as much as over 30%
the speed of light. The only explanation was
that they must have been so distant that their
apparent speed was actually the expansion
of the universe moving them away from us.
But these enormous distances meant that quasars
couldn’t just be stars, but the active cores of
galaxies billions of lightyears away! And it
gets crazier. To appear so bright and loud,
given these vast distances, they are thousands
of times brighter than the entire Milky Way.
Monsters, exploding and screaming into the void
with a violence not thought possible before.
As we mapped the sky, we discovered over a million
quasars. And they all seemed to be very far away.
Looking into space, far away means very
long ago, because their light takes so
long to reach us. Quasars were common
in the early universe, having peaked
in number 10 billion years ago when galaxies,
and the universe itself was still very young.
Let’s go back in time, just 3 billion years after
the big bang and see what was going on back then.
The Incredible Power of Quasars
How could an early baby galaxy be
so incredibly bright and violent?
All that light and radiation couldn’t be
stars, as there weren’t nearly enough of
them. And since galaxies tend
to grow with time by merging,
the starlight from small galaxies shouldn’t
be far brighter than any galaxy today.
There’s only one way to generate the vast
amounts of energy a quasar shines with:
feeding supermassive black holes. We
still don’t know how exactly they formed,
but it seems that every galaxy
has one in their center.
But how can the brightest things
in the universe be black holes,
which trap anything and everything
that crosses their event horizon?
Well the light of a quasar is not coming
from inside these black holes. Rather,
it comes from the space around them, a massive
orbiting disk of gas called an ‘accretion disk.’
Quasars use the same fuel as stars to shine:
Matter. It is just that black holes are the
most efficient engines for converting
matter into energy in the universe.
The energy released by matter falling
into a black hole can be 60 times
greater than that released by nuclear
fusion in the core of a star. Because
the energy released by a black hole comes
from gravity, not from nuclear reactions.
Matter falling into a black hole speeds up to
almost the speed of light before it crosses
the event horizon, buzzing with an incredible
amount of kinetic energy. Of course, once inside
the black hole, it takes that energy with it. You
only get to witness this energy if you drop your
matter in the right way. Fall straight down and
the outside universe gets nothing. But when you
have a lot of matter, it spirals in incredibly
fast towards the event horizon forming a disk.
Collisions between particles and friction heat
it up to hundreds of thousands of degrees.
In a space not much bigger than our solar system,
the core of a galaxy can release many times
more energy than all its stars combined.
This is what a quasar is, a super
massive black hole having a feast.
And these black holes eat a lot. Typical
quasars consume one to a hundred Earth masses
of gas per minute! Ten billion years ago, the
universe was about a third of its current size,
so the intergalactic medium was much less
spread out, meaning the filaments of gas
around quasars could feed them a banquet, making
them vomit insane amounts of light and radiation.
The brightest quasars power jets, tangling the
magnetic field of the matter around them into
a narrow cone. Like a particle accelerator
they launch enormous beams of matter out,
plowing through the circumgalactic medium,
forming plumes of matter that grow to hundreds
of thousands of lightyears in size. It’s
almost unfathomable in scale. A tiny spot
in a galaxy carving out patches of the
universe 100,000s of light years long.
But quasars can’t eat for long,
maybe a few million years,
because their feast ultimately kills their galaxy.
How Quasars Kill Galaxies
Okay, maybe “killing” is a bit of an exaggeration.
A galaxy is still there after its quasar turns
off. But it will never be the same again. Quasars,
being among the hottest and brightest things in
the universe, break their galaxies by heating
them up too much and stopping star formation.
Hot gas cannot form stars. This sounds odd,
because Stars are gas that collapsed in
on itself and then got really hot. But
in a cloud of gas that is already hot,
atoms are moving quickly. When they collide,
they hit hard, exerting pressure that resists
gravity’s squeeze – so hot gas can’t
form stars. Instead, the best gas for
forming stars is already cold, and won’t put up
a fight when it’s time to collapse into a star.
On top of that, quasars push gas out of
their galaxies. Not only does this starve
the quasar, but its galaxy loses
the raw materials for new stars.
As sad as this sounds, it might be a
good thing for life. The alternative
can be far more dangerous: too many stars.
New stars forming is usually followed by
massive stars exploding in supernovae,
so planets would be burned sterile.
But of course it's more complicated. Like the
intricacies of our own planet’s biosphere,
every piece of the galaxy is dependent on and
influencing every other part of the galactic
environment. While hot things, like quasars and
supernovae, tend to push gas out of the galaxy,
shockwaves and quasar jets can also compress
gas, making new stars at least for a short
time. And gas that leaves will mix with gas coming
back in and recycle it back into the galaxy. But
in general we can say that without
things becoming a bit more chill,
we would not exist today. Which
brings us to our final question:
Did the Milky Way Have a Quasar in the Past?
It’s unclear if every galaxy went through a
quasar phase, but understanding distant quasars
may provide clues to the history of the Milky
Way. Galaxies don’t do a good job of preserving
their history. Like sand on a beach the endless
churning mixes away the clues to their past.
It’s possible the Milky Way was once a quasar,
which may have allowed our supermassive
black hole Sagittarius A star to have
grown to 4 million times the mass of the sun.
But sadly we don’t know its ancient history.
And as dormant as it is now, Sagittarius A star
could turn into a quasar in the future. In a few
billion years the Milky Way will merge with
Andromeda. We’ve seen over a hundred ‘double
quasars’ in galaxies smashing together, where
fresh gas is provided for the central black holes.
But it won’t last for long. When galaxies
merge, so do their super massive black holes,
sinking into the center of their new galaxy,
kicking up dust and stars in every direction.
We don’t know whether this will happen, but
it would truly be an incredible sight. Maybe
some beings in the far future are going to
witness it and be in awe of what they see.
But you don’t have to wait that long. There
are already plenty of fascinating things to
explore right here on this planet, right now –
if you have the knowledge to understand them.
To help you with that, we’ve created a series of
lessons to take your scientific knowledge to the
next level. Made in collaboration with our friends
at Brilliant.org, these lessons give you a deeper
understanding of the topics from our most popular
videos, from rabies and mammalian metabolism,
to climate science. There's also a lesson
on black holes, where you can delve into the
fundamental principles behind their formation
and behavior. A deeper understanding will also
help you appreciate their role in powering
the quasars we talked about in this video.
Brilliant is an interactive learning tool
that makes math, science, and computer
science accessible with a hands-on approach.
Because we know that to really learn something,
you’ve got to do it. Think of each lesson as a
one-on-one tutoring version of a Kurzgesagt video.
Brilliant has thousands of other
lessons to explore, as well—from
math-based topics like algebra and probability to
courses around programming and data science.Their
latest course, “How Technology Works,” takes you
inside the technology you use everyday. You’ll
walk in the footsteps of a hacker to discover
why some passwords take decades to crack,
explore how satellites in space know that your
ride share driver is just down the street,
learn why your favorite Kurzgesagt
video might buffer on YouTube, and more.
To get hands-on with Kurzgesagt lessons and
explore everything Brilliant has to offer,
you can start your free, 30-day trial
by signing up at Brilliant.org/nutshell.
There’s even an extra perk for Kurzgesagt viewers:
the first 200 people to use the link get 20%
off an annual membership once their trial ends.
We love seeing how the gears interlock
with our research – Brilliant gives you
the tools to understand how
everything fits together.
We know you’ve been waiting for a long time.
Let’s reveal the next Limited Edition Pin:
It’s the Dyson Sphere. This very special pin set
represents our dream for the future of humanity.
Charge it with energy from the sun and it will
glow in the dark. Pre-order is available for
only 72h, so order now before time runs out. The
next limited edition pin will be revealed soon.